THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WANT TO BRING IN
ARI FLEISCHER, FORMER PRESS
SECRETARY AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, I LEAN ON YOU TODAY
FOR WHAT SHOULD THE MESSAGE BE
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE TO AMERICAN
COMPANIES AND WORKERS AT THIS
POINT?
>> IT ALWAYS HAS TO BE TWO
PARTS, ASSURANCE OF PEOPLE DON’T
GO TOO FAR AND THINK THE WORSE
IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN IT’S
NOT.
AND TWO, ABSOLUTE REALISM.
PEOPLE WANT TO BE LEVELED WITH.
THEY WANT TO BE TOLD HOW
DANGEROUS IS IT, HOW SAFE IS MY
FAMILY, WHAT DO I NEED TO DO?
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS THE
ADMINISTRATION MUST DO EACH AND
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> Harris: AND DO YOU THINK
THAT HAS HAPPENED TO THIS POINT?
>> I DO.
HIS CRITICISMS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GETTING, HE’S
GETTING IT BECAUSE HE IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP HERE THAT IS WHY
THEY ARE PILING ON.
I THINK ANY PRESIDENT WOULD BE
GOING THROUGH A VERY DIFFICULT
PERIOD WHEN THE FACTS ARE LIKE
THEY ARE IN THIS CASE.
THE ONLY CRITICISM I HAVE IS I
THINK THE PRESIDENT GOT STUCK IN
INDIA ONE DAY TOO LATE.
IF HE HAD COME BACK ONE DAY
EARLIER, I THINK HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN AHEAD OF THE STORM THAT ALL
OF A SUDDEN GATHERED.
IT WAS A DAY AND THE OFFICIAL
SAID CDC, IT IS NOT A QUESTION
IF BUT WHEN.
THAT ALARMED EVERYONE AND LUNCH
US WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
>> Harris: THAT IS
INTERESTING.
I HAVEN’T EXACTLY HEARD BUT
MAYBE I MISSED IT, MANY PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT THIS, THERE WAS A
POINT IN TIME THAT YOU SAW THE
MESSAGE NEEDED TO SHIFT.
AND SO, WHERE ARE WE GOING NOW
WITH THIS?
WE GET THIS 5:00 P.M. DAILY
BRIEFING NOW OR AT LEAST THAT IS
STARTING TO PICK UP, SOME
REGULARITY.
BUT WHAT KIND OF MESSAGING WITH
WHAT REGULARITY NEEDS TO COME?
AND FROM WHOM?
DO WE NEED AS MANY VOICES
TELLING US THINGS?
>> THE PROBLEM IS FEAR AND THE
PROBLEM IS CONFIDENCE.
THOSE WORRIES THAT PEOPLE HAVE
COME OF ARE DRIVEN REALLY BY
WHAT THEY ARE HEARING, WHAT THEY
ARE SEEING, WHAT IS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
SO IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE PRESIDENT AND ALL THE
EXPERTS AROUND IT WITH DAILY AND
THEY ARE VAST EXPERTS TO ADDRESS
THE CONFIDENCE AND THE PEER
QUESTIONS.
THAT MEANS CALM, REALISTIC,
ACCURATE EXPRESSIONS FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THAT MEANS THE PRESIDENT TO SEND
THE BROADEST SIGNAL OF
REASSURANCE AND THE EXPERTS TO
TALK ON A LEVEL OF EXACTLY WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
THIS WILL START TO REVERSE WHEN
SCIENCE GETS A HOLD OF IT.
THAT IS THE DIFFICULT PART, HERE
IS.
YOU DON’T KNOW HOW LONG THAT IS
UNTIL THE MEDICINE WORKS.
THE VACCINE COMES IN NEXT YEAR.
BUT BETWEEN NOW AND THEN COME AT